welcome to CBS this morning we have
breaking news from the Middle East at
this hour Iran says that it shot down an
American drone flying over its territory
raising fears that a larger military
conflict could break out in the region
details are in dispute but US officials
confirm an Iranian missile down to try
John drone similar to this one the u.s.
says the surveillance drone was flying
over the Strait of Hormuz in
international airspace
Charlie Dagon is in fujairah one of the
United Arab Emirates near the strip that
strategic water weight Charlie what's
the latest reaction from Iran well
Anthony today iran's Foreign Ministry
described that US drone as a provocation
and that by shooting it down there a
quote sending a clear and precise
message to America the downing of the
drone overnight is just the latest
episode in what has become a simmering
conflict being waged between the two
countries on many fronts in Saudi Arabia
Iranian backed Yemeni rebels claimed
responsibility for a missile strike on a
water desalination plant in Iraq four
separate attacks including one where
iranian-backed militias are blamed for
firing rockets that slammed into an oil
facility housing ExxonMobil wounding
three prompting the company to evacuate
all foreign personnel and this latest
attack over strategic waterways a
campaign of aggression blamed on Iran or
its proxies and coming right on the
heels of last week's attacks the two oil
tankers here in the Dolf of Oman we got
to witness the aftermath for the first
time aboard u.s. gunboats that brought
us alongside the damaged tanker kakuka
courageous up close you can see the
force of the blast sitting right above
the waterline at this point of the
investigation all American Navy
investigators will tell us is the blast
and some of the evidence left behind
from it bears a striking similarity to
the kind of limpet mine
used by the Iranian military part of the
evidence being piled up by Navy
investigators in the case against Iran
which continues to deny any involvement
this morning the commander of Iran's
Revolutionary Guard warned that while
Iran doesn't want a war with anyone it's
ready for one in the midst of all this
regional tension president Trump is due
to meet with Russian President Vladimir
Putin next week at the g20 summit you
can bet that Iran will be high up on
that agenda
Anthony Charlie d'Agata in the United
Arab Emirates thanks charlie